דיאגונליזציה קוונטית של Krylov או בקיצור KQD מתייחסת לפתרון בעיית ערך מטריצה
על ידי הטלת המטריצה לתת-מרחב שמוכן על מחשב קוונטי בהתאם לשיטת Krylov, גישה
חזקה מאלגברה לינארית קלאסית. לאורך הסרטון הזה נחקור למה שיטת Krylov שימושית
ואיך ומתי ליישם אותה על מחשבים קוונטיים.
אז מה זה שיטת Krylov? נניח שיש לנו מטריצה H שקשורה למאמץ מדעי או עסקי עם n שורות ו-n
עמודות. אנחנו מעוניינים בערך העצמי הנמוך ביותר e0 ובוקטור העצמי המתאים psi 0. בואו נגדיר
וקטור התחלתי v שיכול להיות מונע מהמבנה של h או שיכול להיות אקראי לחלוטין. תת-מרחב Krylov
מסדר r שאנחנו כותבים k r נוצר על ידי הפעלת h על הוקטור
ההתחלתי הזה r פחות אחת פעמים תוך הוספת התוצאה של כל הפעלת h עוקבת
לקבוצת וקטורי הפריסה כלומר kr הוא המרחב הנפרס על ידי הוקטורים v
hv h בריבוע וכן הלאה. הוקטורים האלה לא יהיו בדרך כלל אורתוגונליים.
באופן קלאסי, אנחנו לרוב מבצעים תהליך אורתוגונליזציה מאוד דומה לתהליך גרם-שמידט. מתחילים
בנרמול הוקטור ההתחלתי V וקוראים לתוצאה V0. אז לוקטור הבא HV, מחסירים את
ההטלה שלו על V0 כדי להפוך את שני הוקטורים לאורתוגונליים. אז מנרמלים את התוצאה. ממשיכים ככה,
מפעילים שוב את H והופכים את התוצאה לאורתוגונלית לכל הוקטורים שנוספו קודם עד שבונים R
וקטורים אורתונורמליים הנדרשים לפרוס את תת-מרחב Krylov ה-R-ממדי שלכם.
ברגע שיש לכם את תת-המרחב הזה, מטילים את המטריצה עליו ומלכסנים את המטריצה המוטלת הקטנה יותר. יש
עדינויות והרחבות, אבל זו שיטת Krylov ברמה הפשוטה ביותר שלה.
כדי לקבל תחושה טובה יותר של איך זה עובד, בואו נסתכל על דוגמה טריוויאלית. אם H היא המטריצה הזו ו-V נבחר להיות הוקטור
הזה, אז נתחיל בנרמול V. כדי ליצור את הוקטור השני בתת-מרחב Krylov, מפעילים
פעם אחת את H על הוקטור ההתחלתי שלנו ואז הופכים את התוצאה לאורתוגונלית ל-V0.
קצת אלגברה נותנת את זה עבור V1.
זה לא שימושי למטריצות כל כך קטנות ובדרך כלל לא היינו עוצרים בממד Krylov של שתיים. אבל אם היינו
מטילים את H על מרחב Krylov החדש שלנו K2, היינו עושים את זה באמצעות מטריצה V
שיש לה וקטור Krylov לכל עמודה ואת הצמוד ההרמיטי שלה שיש לו וקטורי Krylov לשורות. ואז היינו
מקבלים את המטריצה הזו.
למטריצה הזו טכנית יש ממד נמוך יותר מהמקורית שלנו. ברור שההקטנה הזו לא שימושית בסקאלה
הזו. השיטה הזו מיועדת להקטנת מטריצות עם אלפים רבים או אפילו מיליוני שורות ועמודות
לכמות קטנה. אז למה שיטות Krylov שימושיות? מסתבר שהמרשם הפשוט הזה
של פעולת אופרטור הוא לעיתים קרובות הדרך היעילה ביותר להתקרב למצב הערך הנמוך ביותר או מצב היסוד של אופרטור
מטריצה. בואו נהפוך את זה קצת יותר מפורש אם כי נשאיר הוכחה מלאה לטקסט הנלווה. אנחנו רוצים
לפתור בעיה מהצורה h פועל על הוקטור x נותן לנו קבוע כלשהו כפול הוקטור x. בואו נתחיל עם
ניחוש של הוקטור העצמי שלנו x0. זה רק פתרון מקורב. יש לו שגיאה שאנחנו קוראים לה e0. עכשיו אנחנו רוצים
לעשות עדכון של הניחוש הזה שנקרא לו x1 שאנחנו מקווים שישפר את הקירוב שלנו. אפשר לבטא את זה בתור
ה-x0 המקורי פלוס תיקון כלשהו p0 שעדיין צריך להיקבע. אפשר
לחזור על התהליך הזה באופן איטרטיבי ולהוסיף עוד ועוד וקטורי תיקון pi.
ברור שאנחנו רוצים שהשגיאה תקטן אבל זה לא רק המצב שמעניין אותנו. אנחנו גם מעוניינים בפעולה
של h על המצב הזה. אז הגודל שאנחנו באמת רוצים למזער הוא הנורמת-H של השגיאה הזו או הנורמה של
פעולת h על השגיאה הזו.
עכשיו אפשר לראות שזה ביטוי שמערב את p0 ואפשר לשאול את עצמנו אילו בחירות של p ממזערות
את נורמת-H של השגיאה הכי ביעילות. מאיזה מרחב צריך לבחור את התיקון? בתנאים
מסוימים כמו כש-h סימטרית וחיובית מוגדרת, בחירת r התיקונים הראשונים מתוך kr מתבררת
כאופטימלית. במילים פשוטות יותר, אנחנו צריכים דרך כלשהי להכין תת-מרחב טוב שעליו נוכל
להטיל את ההמילטוניאן שלנו. ובמקרים רבים, תת-מרחב Krylov הוא המרחב הנפרס על ידי וקטורי התיקונים היעילים
ביותר לניחוש ההתחלתי שלנו.
להוכחה אמיתית, ראו את הטקסט הנלווה לסרטון הזה.
כל מה שתיארנו עד כה אפשר לעשות באופן קלאסי. אז, איך ומתי נשתמש במחשב קוונטי?
עבור מטריצות גדולות מאוד, שיטת Krylov יכולה לדרוש זמני חישוב ארוכים וכמויות גדולות של זיכרון. הזמן
הנדרש לפעולת מטריצה של H על V מסקייל כמו N בריבוע במקרה הגרוע ביותר.
וזה נעשה עבור כל וקטור שאנחנו רוצים בתת-המרחב שלנו. ממד תת-המרחב R הוא בדרך כלל לא חלק משמעותי
מ-N ולעיתים קרובות מסקייל כמו לוג של N. אז יצירת כל הוקטורים מסקיילת
כמו סדר N^2 log N.
למרות שיש צעדים אחרים כמו אורתוגונליזציה, זה הסקיילינג הדומיננטי שכדאי לזכור.
מחשוב קוונטי מאפשר לנו לשנות אילו תכונות של הבעיה קובעות את הסקיילינג של הזמן והמשאבים
הנדרשים. במקום תלות בגודל המטריצה n לכל אורך הדרך, נראה דברים כמו מספר השוטים ומספר
מחרוזות Pauli הלא-קומוטטיביות שמרכיבות המילטוניאן.
בואו נחקור איך זה עובד.
נזכור שהאופרטור שמפתח בזמן מצב קוונטי הוא האקספוננט של iH חלקי h bar. וזה
מאוד נפוץ, במיוחד במחשוב קוונטי, להוריד את h bar מהסימון.
דרך אחת להבין ואפילו לממש פונקציה אקספוננציאלית כזו של אופרטור היא להסתכל על פיתוח טור
הפורייה שלה. שימו לב שהפעולה הזו על וקטור התחלתי V כלשהו נותנת סכום של איברים